we did have conference calls with
governors who were keeping their states
open
uh and uh you know we we just organized
that ourselves we were all republicans
but we had weekly sometimes bi-weekly
phone calls with learning what we could
learn about the virus from each other it
was a governor's only call
also learning what other people were
doing what measures they were taking
what they were recommending
but we also made sure that that call
only stayed
for the governors that kept their states
open and every week
less and less governors were on the call
so
as you mentioned earlier what sort of
put you on the map nationally was the
covid situation and that you didn't go
for lockdowns and you fought the system
and all that as you may know i lived in
california for most of kovid i now live
in the free state of florida and as i
keep telling my audience it's like
living in another country i genuinely
feel that i left one country and moved
to another which is the beauty of
federalism can you talk a little bit
about those first couple weeks of covid
the pressure you were under and how you
made your decisions uh you know who you
were taking advice from et cetera
well i would say it was
it was uh immense pressure you know
we were told right away before the virus
even came to the state of south dakota
that i would have over 300 000 people
die
from this virus that was coming and that
i needed to do something about it to
slow down the spread and protect people
who were vulnerable
so i think i did what every other
governor did talk to a lot of health
officials and experts studied the virus
learned from other states when they were
first affected what i did differently
was i believe i spent a lot more time
with my general counsel
a lot of time with constitutional
attorneys i really wanted to understand
what my job was as governor
and what my job wasn't what authority i
did not have because i just believe that
when leaders overstep their authority
especially in a time of crisis like that
that that's really when we break the
foundation of this country i knew for a
fact
i did not want to be the governor who
did that so south dakota did end up
being the only state that never once
closed a business or mandated anything
while other states were closing beaches
and closing businesses and stopping
big meetings and gatherings south dakota
did something very different in fact i
was
shocked and surprised how people were
rolling over and giving up their
freedoms in many states
so we went on the offense um you know we
ran a national advertising campaign
right away in 2020 inviting everybody to
come to south dakota well while your
state's locked down come and spend time
here be free
and
hundreds of thousands of people came
they came and spent some time here and
then many of those people went back home
packed up their families and moved here
so it's been an incredible testimony to
to what happened in that in that
pandemic i think the very day that crazy
video of the cop chasing down the guy in
malibu on the beach you remember that
[ __ ]
absolutely i remember that day and i
lived not too far from there i i saw you
on fox saying you know we're going to
stay open and really thinking man this
this is what's happening in america
right now it's just it's just many many
different countries so were you talking
to other governors also i mean i you
know some like desantis obviously we're
doing something a lot closer to what you
were doing but you know gavin newsom who
was my governor in cali was obviously
doing something very different ho chill
up in or at the time it was cuomo in new
york but now ho chill has continued a
lot of that stuff
well we talked a lot not so much with
democrat governors you know there would
be different conference calls through
the national governors association that
were hosted and facilitated but i
learned quickly
that those weren't beneficial they we
weren't getting any new information from
them and that we needed to prioritize
where my time was being spent we did
have conference calls with governors who
were keeping their states open
and
you know we we just organized that
ourselves we were all republicans but we
had weekly sometimes bi-weekly phone
calls with learning what we could learn
about the virus from each other it was a
governor's only call
also learning what other people were
doing what measures they were taking
what they were recommending
but we also made sure that that call
only stayed
for the governors that kept their states
open and every week
less and less governors were on the call
it was kind of interesting how
candid we were you know so we'd get on
that call and and somebody would say hey
guys
i gotta let you know this is my last
phone call i'll be on my entire team is
telling me that i've got to shut down
businesses because the spread's getting
too bad so i'm just here to let you know
that tomorrow i'm putting out a press
release and
closing this date and and i won't be on
these calls anymore
and we would say okay and then there was
less and less so there was times where
it got down to 12 of us and then a week
later there was eight of us and
then there was less of us and down until
i was the only one left so it was it was
interesting um times but i also many of
those republican governors maybe didn't
have the situation that i had either you
know i
had an incredible executive team that
when i made a decision they said okay
that's the decision and they did it and
and
my hospital administrators were very
involved we talked many times a day
when we made decisions it was based on
science it was not based on what was
playing on the news
that was very helpful they were common
sense reasonable people who want to take
care of each other and the state
partnered with them in ways that i don't
think happened in other states our
national guard
and other entities were heavily involved
in helping them
build up capacity and staffing
uh very innovative in how we approached
it that i think allowed us to do what we
did
what kind of pushback were you getting
behind the scenes even if you had
support in the state i would imagine you
know there had to be some calls from
maybe people at the nih or cdc or just
whatever legal people whatever just
saying hey you can stay open but we're
coming for you basically one way or
another yeah i think we got push i mean
we got pushback from every angle
everywhere and and even the national
media made it worse because they just
specifically targeted me there would be
hot spots all over the country but all
they talked about at night
on the news was south dakota and our
meat packing plant or the sturgis
motorcycle bike rally or this
irresponsible event we were going to be
hosting at mount rushmore you know they
specifically went after
me in a way that we'd never seen before
and we saw
the cdc officials and nih and fauci
specifically attack me along with
elizabeth warren and rachel maddow night
after night but we also you know
recognized too that people in my state
weren't necessarily supportive either
you know there was times where it was
hard to find
a lot of encouragement even from people
who lived here that my lieutenant
governor tells the story that he would
get phone calls from even our best
supporters that would say hey you got to
get the governor in line this is gonna
this is gonna kill her politically and
she's got to start falling in line with
these other governors and you know to
his credit and to my executive team
they they said she is firm in her
decision
she has already decided this she doesn't
have the authority therefore she's not
going to overstep and
and we are in in line with her and and
that that made it
a wonderful thing for me because many
times those contentious phone calls they
were taking they didn't necessarily
always tell me about they knew where i
was
and we were a team taking care of people
together did you ever have a moment
where you almost cracked and said okay
i'm gonna have to do some lockdowns or
some version of something like did the
pressure ever get to that point where
you got close
you know i don't think i ever got close
although it was hard there were days
that
that i would say
you know i hung up a phone or got off a
zoom call where i thought
man i don't know
how much longer i can do this you know
my family was pretty remarkable i have a
son that's now 20 but he was
18 at the time that sat by my desk for
18 hours a day and just sat there um so
and i think it was to remind me that
somebody was going to love me no matter
what you know and then when i got off a
a phone call that was contentious
because i spent a lot of time managing
other leaders i spent a lot of time
you know having conference calls with
mayors
with city council members with county
commissioners you know once i made a
decision i spent a ton of time
communicating with them about why i was
making the decision i was making but
when i would hang up with a phone call
that obviously was contentious or
stressful you know in a way he would say
mom
let's go shoot baskets for five minutes
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell